[Music]
psychedelic drugs are the most
misunderstood and underrated therapies
in psychiatry
they were medicines from the 1950s to
the late 1960s when they were banned
because people started using them and
voting in gangs war in Vietnam and since
that ban there's been no research and
we've had 50 years of people deprived of
their therapeutic potential and in the
last couple of years my group and others
such as the Bettie Foundation have been
fighting back to try to restore some
semblance of rationality in this debate
we've shown that if you use magic
mushrooms you can lift chronic
depression in people who failed multiple
antidepressants with just a single dose
of psilocybin the active ingredient in
magic mushrooms and these effects can
last for months this is a potentially
very powerful revolutionary treatment
for chronic depression similar studies
have been done using again magic
mushrooms in addictions to cigarettes
into alcohol we're also now setting up a
trial in obsessive-compulsive disorder
but all this research is extremely
difficult than very expensive because
the drugs are called illegal drugs
they're put in a schedule which means it
there they're treated as if they are
more dangerous than drugs like fentanyl
or heroin which will way more dangerous
and more sought-after so my hope is that
this debate we've had here in the
communications we've had here will
inspire people to ask the question why
don't we change the law to allow doctors
to use these drugs in the first instance
in research as the research turns out
positively let's roll that out into
clinical practice one of the things
we're trying to do is help people with
OCD break down their repetitive
compulsive thinking patterns and we are
we think this psilocybin magic mushroom
juice will be a way of doing that we
understand that people throw CDR very
scared about letting go so we're not
going to give them a full trip because I
don't think they did sign up for that
but what
we're gonna do is use a lower dose of
psilocybin to help make their brains
more flexible so they can better engage
with the ongoing psychotherapy the
behavior therapy that they're using it
present so it's not a it's not a kind of
it doesn't deal with it in one go it's
about working better with CBT and
allowing them to not associate
themselves too strongly with any
individual floor that they may be
getting stuck on it's a way of like the
kind of like that's right we see we're
hoping and of course a trial hasn't
started as call funding yet so we're you
know basically we've developed a vision
we're gonna go for funding but the idea
is that maybe with low-dose almost a
micro dose of psilocybin we could help
people's brains be lubricated enough
that they can better engage with the
psychotherapy with the CBT or the
behavior therapy and maybe also the
brain might be lubricated enough to
learn better so they've not only engaged
with the therapy better but they might
get a better outcomes from the therapy
so there's regulatory problems in the UK
but the fundamental problem working with
psychedelics is it every one of 197
countries in the United Nations have
signed up to ban these drugs the only
exception was in Netherlands and the
Netherlands were very clever just as
they were very clever about cannabis
very clever about the mushrooms because
when they were told to ban the mushroom
they banned the mushroom but they didn't
ban the truffle which is the bit of the
mushroom underground from which the
mushroom grows so in the Netherlands
truffles are legal and there's a huge
therapeutic industry now of people how
going from Britain and also other parts
of of Europe to have therapy sessions
with psilocybin based on the truffles
for modder bates
talks and interviews subscribe today to
the institutes of arson ideas at iai TV
you